en este vídeo me gustaría platicar con
ustedes acerca de varias conversiones
que tengan que ver con grados y radiales
esta va a ser la idea detrás este vídeo
lo primero que quiero que recordemos son
las dos igualdades importantísimas que
vimos en el vídeo pasado si ustedes se
acuerdan la primera igualdad muy
importante que decíamos es que cuando
nosotros dábamos una vuelta entera a la
circunferencia teníamos dos radiales y
lo metíamos en radiales o si nosotros lo
medimos en los grados que tanto
conocemos eran 360 grados y de hecho lo
habíamos puesto como grados escrito para
que no nos confundamos sobre estas dos
medidas angulares y después dijimos
bueno si yo divido tanto ésta como ésta
entre dos entonces me va a quedar mi
segunda igualdad importante que decía
que irradian es es lo mismo que 180
grados irradian es es igual a 180 grados
es decir cuando dábamos media vuelta
solamente la mitad de la vuelta entera y
en el vídeo pasado también sacamos el
valor de un radial y el valor de un
grado por lo tanto vamos a recordarlo si
yo lo que quisiera saber es cuánto
un radiante entonces lo que voy a hacer
es dividir ambos lados de la ecuación
entre pink y así me va a quedar una
nueva igualdad que de hecho en esta
ocasión vamos a utilizar bastante
entonces vamos a hacerlo yo sé que si yo
divido tanto el primer lado como un
segundo lado de la ecuación entre pin me
va a quedar del lado izquierdo un radial
y entre primera uno y del lado derecho
me va a quedar 180 entre pi grados por
lo tanto ya sé cuánto vale un radial en
términos de grado y esto era muy
importante y bueno ahora de manera
análoga voy a sacar el valor de un grado
para saber el valor de un grado en
radiales lo que voy a hacer es dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 180 me
va a quedar que pie entre 180 radiales
es igual a 183 180 que es 1 y por lo
tanto me queda un grado y ya con esto
tengo la equivalencia de un radio en
grados y viceversa de un grado en
radiales ahora la pregunta del millón de
dólares es si yo tengo 30 grados como
convierto esta medida que está dada en
grados
a medida en radiales y bueno mejor
déjenme escribirlo así
grados no quiero pasar a radiales y lo
que se me ocurre hacer es multiplicar
por lo que yo sé que vale un grado en
radiales la idea que hay detrás aquí es
cancelar los grados por lo tanto en la
parte de arriba voy a poner lo que valen
los radiales y en la parte de abajo voy
a poner lo que valen los grados de tal
manera que cuando yo multiplique 30
grados por esta cantidad que voy a poner
aquí los grados con los grados se vayan
y solamente me queden radiales y bueno
qué sé yo
yo sé que radian es a cuántos grados
equivalen bueno y radiales son 180
grados y lo tenemos aquí arriba irradian
es es igual a 180 grados un radio no es
igual a 180 entre pri grados o como lo
quieran ver por lo tanto aquí arriba voy
a poner fin de tal manera que arriba me
van a quedar irradian es y abajo voy a
poner 180 grados porque yo sé que
irradian es son 180 grados y por lo
tanto esta fracción me da 1 piratean es
entre 180 grados me da 1 y lo único que
estoy haciendo es multiplicando por 111
especial y ahora sí 30
por pi entre 180 el 30 de 30 grados por
el pie de radiant es entre 180 lo que
vaya en grados y todo esto se puede
simplificar a piece sextos radiales
esperen esperen esperen porque primero
que poner aquí que estos son radiales ya
los grados con los grados se cancelaron
y por lo tanto mi resultado va a ser
sextos radiales 30 grados valen pi sobre
6 radiales y ya encontré mi primer
ejercicio de grados a radiales ahora qué
va a pasar al revés si yo tengo pi
tercios radiales y lo quiero pasar esto
a medida angular en grados bueno como yo
tengo radiales multiplicando ahora lo
que voy a buscar es que los radiales me
queden dividiendo para que se cancelen
entonces voy a poner grados arriba abajo
radiales para que se cancelen y voy a
utilizar otra vez mi segunda igualdad
yo sé que 180 grados es lo mismo que
pitt radiales es decir 180 me queda
arriba y para abajo y por lo tanto se
van a poder cancelar los radiales con
los radiales y mi resultado me va a
quedar en grados así que vamos a hacerlo
radiales y radiales se van vamos a
cancelar vamos
un pique multiplica y un pique de
evidenciaban 180 entre 3
es lo mismo que 60 eso está fácil 60 y
mi resultado me va a dar en grados 60
grados
ok perfecto ya llevo dos a ver vamos a
ver un tercer ejercicio ahora yo quiero
transformar 45 grados 45 grados a
radiales entonces voy a usar lo mismo
los grados se tienen que quedar abajo
los radiales arriba de tal forma que se
cancelen los grados con los grados y los
radiales queden arriba como que ya
andamos bastante contentos porque
estamos entendiendo mejor lo que está
pasando entonces nos va a quedar esto
multiplicado por pi radiales entre 180
grados entre 180 grados y esto es por mi
segunda equivalencia favorita que saben
que siempre utilizo y de hecho déjame
ponerlo mejor así esto no me está
gustando nada porque aquí tengo grados y
radiales y mejor dejen de escribirlo
todo todo todo en grados porque nunca me
ha gustado esto que se confunda podemos
confundirnos y no sabes de qué estamos
hablando entonces mejor déjame escribir
otra vez todo para que no tengamos
problema alguno
me quedan 45 grados pero en lugar de
ponerle la abuelita arriba voy a poner
grados 45 grados y voy a multiplicarlo
por este 1 especial que sale de mi
segunda igualdad que dice que piratean
es son 180 grados recuerda que de vido
entre grados para que los grados se
cancelen y ahora si ya están grados con
grados se van y me va a quedar solamente
45 pib entre 180 y radiant es los grados
con los grados se van y solamente me
quedan el resultado en radiales pero 45
entre 180 es lo mismo que un cuarto o
dicho de otra manera esto es lo mismo
que pi entre 4 radiales y cuartos
radiales ven no está tan difícil ya
vamos mejorando bastante en nuestra
transformación de grados radiales y de
radio en sagrados así que vamos hacer un
cuarto ejercicio para acabar este vídeo
ahora me voy a tomar negativo pin medios
radiales menos pin medios radiales como
lo pasó a grados o no changos ahora son
negativos que vamos a hacer lo que
quiero hacer es cancelar los radiales
para pasarlo a grados
abajo me van a quedar los radiales y
arriba los grados entonces 180 grados
entre piedra dianes no me espanto por el
signo menos ya más relajado porque veo
que esto no está tan difícil y entonces
radiantes irradian se van pipí se van me
va a quedar 180 entre 2 lo cual son 90
grados pero con este signo menos me
quedan menos 90 grados o menos 90 grados
con la bolita arriba y al final recuerda
que un ángulo negativo es simple y
sencillamente girar hacia el otro lado
así que con esto acabamos estos
ejercicios y voy a seguir haciendo más
ejercicios en los siguientes vídeos